I'm delighted that y'all are here I'm
Ron Bailey on the science correspondent
for Reason magazine and I'm going to be
giving a talk that I've called the end
of doom which is the title the working
title of a book of mine that I'm still
working on kind of give you a preview of
some of the things I'll be talking about
in that book I'm starting with this
particular slide which is the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse which is part
of the Christian mythology and what this
tip can be translated as is pestilence
war famine and death and it turns out
that all four of those are being reduced
in the modern age pestilence is way down
war is also way down that you have
probably less chance of being killed in
a violent conflict today then you would
have had in any other time in all of
human history famine is way down we'll
get a bit talking about that but there
are the lowest percentage of people on
the planet or malnourished than ever
before in history and even death is way
down it's still inevitable but it is way
down basically human life expectancy has
increased from an average of forty seven
years of 19 55 to 70 years today so what
I would like to talk about what if
organizing is what I'm calling four
horsemen of the modern abundance we're
calling a peak population peaked
farmland peak pollution and peak nothing
look at to that one in a minute so this
is what overpopulation looks like this
is the face of overpopulation this is
paul ehrlich who wrote the population
bomb in 1968 and he said the battle
defeat all of humanity is over in the
1970s the world will undergo famines
hundreds of millions of people are going
to starve to death in spite of any
crashed programs embarked upon now well
that didn't happen so this is paul
ehrlich today and this he just published
in the Proceedings of the Royal Society
earlier this year the human predicament
is driven by overpopulation over
consumption of Natural Resources and of
and the use of necessarily
environmentally damaging technologies
and
socio-economic political arrangements to
service Homo sapiens aggregate
consumption by the way the
socio-economic political arrangement
they speaking of it becomes clear an
article is democratic capitalism he
thinks that's just a terrible way to
organize the world so he's still
predicting doom but what's happening
actually here's a chart showing what is
happening total fertility trends total
fertility is basically the average
number of children that an average woman
is expected to have over the course of
her life and it's been collapsing and
has been following it in 1960 was around
5.5 children per woman over the course
of her life it is down to two point four
and it's collapsing in all the regions
of the world this is the latest data or
projections i should say out of the
united nations every two years they do
what they call a population revision and
this particular one they give you a
medium a constant fertility a high in a
low trajectory that put that that
population could go now the difference
between the high and the low is
essentially one child over the over the
next 60 years or so now the question is
which trajectory would is it will is it
likely to go on the typically people
take the median as the the most likely
though that hasn't historically been
proven to be the case and if that were
to be the case by the end of this
century global population will have
increased up to a little over 10 billion
people you'll notice it will not have
doubled again we most of us in this room
have lived through the last human
population doubling and that will ever
occur again but the lower trajectory is
has been the one that seems to be the
more likely one over the past few years
so what is going on well I'd like to
give you three reasons to expect the
lower trajectory one is this
particularly total fertility and GDP per
capita what you find is over here at the
top end where women are still having
five six and seven kids they're having
incomes below a thousand dollars below
five hundred dollars per capita and then
what you see as you go out to get to
twenty five twenty thousand thirty
thousand dollars
the fertility is below 2.1 children
which is replacement the world is going
to get wealthier over the course of the
21st century and that particular dynamic
will continue to go now there's another
piece of data that i don't have here but
there's some wonderful work that's been
done by some anthropologists recently at
the University of Michigan and a
university of connecticut where what
they've done they've looked at a woman's
life expectancy and it turns out that if
women can expect to live only up to age
60 they have five children on average
but when they get to when they can
expect to live over 75 it falls to 1.5
children over their lives so what it was
happening is a certain extent these
anthropologists think there's a kind of
natural history of reproduction if you
don't think you're going to be around
you have a lot more kids because you're
living in a violent chaotic poor place
and you want some of your kids to
survive so you have more kids and with
if we're if you think you can live to 75
or so instead of having were kids you
and have fewer and invest more resources
in them and that is how you change the
way you if you will reproduce the other
interesting statistic was done by an
economist at Wheaton College called Seth
Norton he was I wanted to do this myself
and when I came across a study I was
damned he basically did a correlation
between economic freedom and rule of law
and the number of children over the time
that that each each Society has I don't
think it'll shock this particular
audience but if your rule of law
quotient was low or your economic
freedom quotient was low again the
average was five children per woman on
the other hand if you were high it was
beloved two children per woman so again
these three things all go together
longer life expectancy greater wealth
and greater freedom will all tend to go
on that lower trajectory of population
growth over the rest of the century
let's kind of pointed that and I tend to
agree view this this was a statement
that was just made by Sanjeev San y'all
who works at deutsche bank and was just
published less than a month ago and I
think he's right in our view
a global for Carol Lee will fall to
replacement rate in less than 15 years
that is from 2.4 today to less than 2.1
in 15 years globally and will peak at
8.7 and go down to eight billion I think
it's going to be even lower than that
but we'll see uh who is Norman Borlaug
you cross he was the father of the Green
Revolution that is correct he is the
person who has probably saved more human
lives in any single human being in all
of human history and is a great hero and
a great friend of reasons that when he
was alive so peak farmland is one of the
other forces of abundance so I'm talking
about this is Jesse ossible who works at
Rockefeller University in the human
environment program he's the director of
it and they just had an article in
population development review where
they've calculated what's happening with
farmland all around the globe and their
conclusion is that humanity now stands
at peak farmland and the 21st century
will see the release of vast areas of
land hundreds of millions of hectares
more than twice area France for nature
agriculture is becoming so productive
that we will be able to return millions
of acres of land back to nature over the
course of this century so how is this
working well as you can see unlike Paul
air like the family claimed the famines
didn't occur and they didn't occur
because what you see is a coin wheat and
rice all essentially tripled in
productivity over the last 50 years or
so and I should point out that that
while they tripled that amount of food
that was available to people tripled the
population only doubled so the amount of
calories per capita the world has has
decreased in morm asleep which is why
starvation has declined so significantly
and so this is another way of looking at
it if we had maintained the same crop
productivity that we had in 1960 until
today and tried to feed the world's
population that exists today about 7.2
billion people what would have happened
is we would have had to plow down an
additional three billion acres of land
to do that now how much is that skin hit
earth is the way that Jessie ossible
refers to it if crop yields had
stuck in nineteen sixty levels the world
would have needed another three billion
acre hectars I'm sorry to feed the
current population about the sum of the
USA canada and china are almost twice of
South America that would have been a
collage achill environmentally very bad
but that's not what happened so I know
the side of crop productivity is
reforestation again more land returning
to nature and this is a some research
that was published in 2006 and the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences we're basically they surveyed
the 50 country the 50 largest countries
50 countries of the largest amounts of
forest land in the world and found that
in fact that when you got to per capita
incomes of forty four thousand six
hundred dollars that basically force
stop being reduced and they start
regrowing again this is something called
the environmental Kuznets curve which
we'll get to momentarily there is I
wanted if one caveat though with this
one of the problems with the forest
around the world is eighty eight percent
of the world's forests are owned by
governments and that has its own
problems shall we say but anyway I
mentioned the environmental Kuznets
curve and the idea here is is that as
people get start developing as I start
trying to feed their families better get
better housing create the wherewithal
for for a better life the environment
decays they care a lot less about
pollution at that point for example if
it rather than feed their family so the
trade-offs are making is more pollution
as so that I can get more goods and
services for my family but at a turning
point when incomes get to a certain
level what happens is we find and
there's a huge amount of literature
supporting this is that people say you
know it's really too polluted around
here I would really like have some
forests to go visit so there so they
start investing in environmental
improvement and so what you have is that
mentioned before the reforestation that
is one of the Kuznets curve that 4646
hundred dollars per capita you find
before station returning and this
happens a lot in a lot of areas of
environmental problems
so let's talk about peak pollution which
is what I mentioned now this is a
complicated chart but bear with me a
little bit this is from the
Environmental Protection Agency I did
not make this stuff up they produce it
you can go and look at for yourself and
what you find is is that US wealth
population pollution trends between 1970
and 2008 the economy more than doubled
in size the amount of miles that we
drove our cars and trucks and so forth
went over increased by one hundred sixty
percent the population increased by
fifty percent the energy consumption
increased by fifty percent and the
carbon emissions carbon dioxide
emissions also increase almost fifty
percent but at the bottom there that
little line going to the bottom air
pollution there's six pollutants that
are basically regulated by the our
government declined at in aggregate by
sixty percent we got much wealthier and
pollution went way down and I have to
say my first time coming out to LA is a
much younger man I used to not see the
mountains I see them all the time now
there has been significant progress in
that area now what to the vexed question
of global warming I was discussing over
over lunch I'm basically considered
myself sort of a lukewarm ER I'll
explain that in a little bit but here we
have what it to do is to show you what
the actual trends are these are
satellite and surface temperature trends
from nineteen seventy nine to twenty
thirteen and there are basically three
different surface data sets that have
been gathered from around the world and
they're the two satellite data sets that
are used over time and what you find it
and this is smooth for I believe a
five-year average and what you find is
there has been an increase in its
nineteen seventy nine the latest
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change report that came out less than a
month ago the physical sciences report
concluded that the temperature has risen
since the 1950s for by about six degree
point six degrees i'm sorry point six
degrees celsius over that period of time
and that which suggests that per decade
increase of temperature
of 0.12 degrees per decade over that
time interestingly enough they even
admitted in that report that the
temperature of the planet the average
temperature again has not actually
increased very much if at all over the
last 15 years they are very confident
the people of the UN are very confident
that the results of their climate change
models are predicting significant
warming for the remainder of the of this
century significant and problematic
warming and so in the latest IPCC report
they give this chart where this trying
to show how accurately their models
follow along with the temperature
observations and what you find is and
it's a little bit hard to see but
essentially what you find is here a
little line in the middle of 73 model
realizations as they call them and it
looks like it's it not a terrible it's a
pretty good fit this kind of toward the
low end but is that what's going on
there are a lot of people who are
critiquing this and one of my favorite
guys is a guy named John Christie who is
a climatologist at the University of
Alabama in Huntsville and he and his
colleague Roy Spencer have been
measuring the temperature of the globe
using satellites since 1979 and they'd
been doing this for their very
significant very important very
well-respected climatologists and what
he did was take those seventy three
models various realizations of them for
the tropical troposphere now you would
expect as it turns out i won't go into
great detail you would expect the
warming to be most easily detected in
the tropical troposphere and what he
finds instead is you see the black line
that's the average of that and at the
bottom there you have the two satellite
records that are run there plus several
weather balloons those little blue and
green figs and what you see is none of
the models actually reproduce those
observations there are brunt they're all
running much too hot and another way to
look at this is he just takes those
averages and you will see there's a
considerable divergence so the IPCC
people acknowledge that there has been
quote unquote hiatus in the warming and
they are very confident their models are
right in the next five years or so
warming should be zoom and it should go
very much faster if it doesn't there's
going to be a big problem with the
science what about peak everything we're
running out of everything aren't we this
is what you hear all the time I'm
calling this section peak nothing I
think this is the right question that we
should ask ourselves all the time these
are two economists European economist in
an article in 2003 where they asked the
following question is it realistic to
predict that knowledge accumulation is
so powerful as to outweigh the physical
limits of physical capital services and
the limited substitution possibilities
of Natural Resources basically our human
being smart enough to overcome
scarcities through their intellectual
powers and the answer is i think yes
let's go to peak oil which i don't hear
anything about peak oil anymore its kind
of just gone away but six years ago it
was all over the place and this was a
CNN report from a group in germany
called energy watch group whose slogan
by the way is because energy needs
objective information they predicted and
you can see here that this little chart
I've embedded there is their predictions
of where oil is going to peek in various
regions of the world but this is it it's
supposedly peaked in 2006 and was going
to go down three percent a year for the
soup for the rest of the maternity
probably and so we would only have half
of as much oil as if Y 2030s we're
currently producing that didn't happen
in fact Leonardo McGarry who is at
Harvard's Belfer Center he used to be an
executive at the Italian energy company
Eenie and he has done an analysis where
he believes that there's a global oil
glut coming global oil output capacity
is likely to grow from 93 million
barrels per day today her day today to
110 million barrels per day by 2020 the
largest increase in a single decade
since the 1980s ah there limits to
growth now this is where we got the peak
everything meme
would suggest years and years ago back
in 1972 the limits to growth basically
was a series of a computer model that
was predicting all kinds of horrible
things about the collapse of
civilization because we're going to run
out of non-renewable resources by the
way I don't know if you know this but
today is the 40th anniversary of the oil
crisis this was the day that OPEC said
we're not going to send you any oil and
so this book seemed to get some
resonance out of that that particular
fact in any case this on the side here
they said that known reserves of these
non-renewable resources would mostly be
gone by the year 2000 and they gave
various states now to be honest and fair
they also said let's assume that there
are five times more than we expected
that to be reserves even if your crunch
those numbers at the expense at the
exponential growth rates they expected
the economy to grow at and there used to
be going we would already be running out
many of these resources anyway so what
happened you can go to the US Geological
Survey you can find out how many
reserves we still have as you can see
the reserves are still much higher some
more than 40 years later after the after
the limits to growth was published now
this particular fellow that I have over
here is wearing the devil's horns is a
favorite economist of mine unfortunately
dead named Julian Simon who wrote a
fabulous book on the ultimate resource
which is human beings among many other
things and he very famously had a bet
with Paul Ehrlich back in between 1980
and 1990 where Paul air licking his
buddies got to pick a market basket of
five medals and the bet was is that it
costs a thousand dollars in 1980 and and
Simon bet that the prices would go down
and therefore if they did go down air
liquide have to pay him the difference
from going down to a thousand or if they
go up then Simon Simon would have to pay
air likely additional amount over a
thousand dollars
and 1990 air lick sent a check without a
note I might add for 576 dot seven cents
to Simon in other words the prices of
that basket of metals went down by more
than fifty percent over that period of
time I should say there is another
analysis prices have been going up
recently and there's an another analysis
by an economist named Sachs which we
could talk about which suggests that
there are super cycles in minerals and
so forth and basically what happens is
that prices go up human ingenuity is
applied and the prices go back down and
he thinks we're at the turning point of
this latest super cycle but that's still
debatable in any case I'd like to
suggest you that doom has been postponed
again and and and the world is likely to
give you become a much better place over
the course of the remainder of this
century anyway thank you very much for
paying attention to me I would love to
hear any questions you might have